for Paul Wedgwood the fruits of the
forest are not only of the sweet variety
I'll take a plant and I'll rub it break
it down so I get the smell and see what
sort of memories get evoked by that so
you've got like add a nice smell or a
citrus smell and you know and any start
thinking or how can I take this
ingredient and knit it into my saw
cuisines down Paul Wedgwood opened his
own restaurant in Edinburgh in 2007 on
the menu you'll find everything from
scallops with pistachio dust to a
miniature version of Scotland's national
dish haggis balls served with wood
pigeon typical Scottish cuisine is
really sort of evolving now there's the
there's a preconception around the world
that it's all deep-fried and not a
healthy you know we've got some of the
best chefs in Scotland now they're each
bringing their their own unique style
and uses of that of our local
ingredients Wedgwood puts a big emphasis
on healthy and low calorie fare his
vegetables are sourced from organic
suppliers earthy in Edinburgh orders its
vegetables straight from small-scale
farms in the local area
it's important because you get you get
the freshest ingredients you get the
full traceability so you know where it's
coming from and who grew it and and when
it came out the ground cauliflower is a
staple of Scottish cuisine Wedgwood
transforms the vegetable into a curry
delight in its own right it comprises
regular and romanesque cauliflower
butter korma paste coconut oil and nuts
first cut the vegetable into thick
slices and then drizzle and oil
and we cook the cauliflower the way we
do is the charring effect adds a real
extra depth of flavor to the cauliflower
which is placed in the oven for 15
minutes preheated to 220 degrees Celsius
part of the cauliflower is trimmed off
and fried in the pan the chef then adds
two big t spoonfuls of the curry paste
and 200 milliliters of coconut milk
leave it to simmer for a short while
and then blend in the mixer and your
curried cauliflower puree is finished
the florets from the romanesque
cauliflower are boiled for three minutes
from the oven just check notes just
started softening through perfect and to
further enhance the rustic flavor the
vegetable is fried in butter so now our
cauliflower is ready we're just gonna
take the the green leaves
there's gonna add these to the hot pan
this is geo-scan a start wilting them
down tiny little bit of rapeseed oil and
that's ready to go
Wedgwood is keen to use every single
part of the vegetable and in the case of
cauliflower that includes the leaves
which serve to lend the dish a nutty
flavor the wilted green leaves finally
sprinkle with crushed cashew nuts and
your charred cauliflower is ready to
serve vegetarian cuisine in mainstream
restaurants it was was an overlooked
thing for for so many years but now in
Scotland where we've got such great
farmers producing such wonderful
vegetables that you know we can actually
create dishes out of these using our our
skills and expertise to really sort of
make these vegetables sing on the plate
a musical compilation that will make you
long for more